اشترك
هذا التحليل والاختبار التفصيلي الهندسي
في نهاية الأعمال قمنا بإنشاء ليمريك
تمت إضافة 85 مليار متر مكعب من الجبال إلى المحمية
وهكذا ، فإن منطقة الدانوب في حقل ساكاريا
إجمالي احتياطيات الغاز الطبيعي في المنطقة
وصلت الكمية إلى 405 مليار متر مكعب.
تم التخطيط للعمل في البئر مسبقًا
ويصل لعمق 4775 متر بهذه الطريقة
انتهى مع باشا من الميناء
تنطبق على البحر الأسود مثل تركيا
لكننا نهتم بشؤوننا الخاصة
سنواصل في البحر الأسود و
الموارد الهيدروكربونية في البحر الأبيض المتوسط
سنواصل البحث ، هذه تركيا.
تماما خارج الصراع
العمل الخاص لبلدنا وقبرص
لا شيء يتجاهل حقوق الأتراك
لم يكن هناك أي محاولة للخطة على الإطلاق
القلب لا يسمح لها أن تنتهي كما آمل
الحفر من الشهر المقبل
تواصل أنشطتها في مجال سكاريا
هل يستمر تركالي في بئر؟